[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
antenne
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour et bien nous sommes aujourd'hui
à argelès sur mer
je dois dire que c'est un endroit
magnifique nous sommes exactement sur la
plage il ya vraiment des milliers et des
milliers de personnes et j'aimerais bien
que vous les entendiez maintenant
applaudir
alors je crois que nous allons les
entendre
il se passe aujourd'hui dans l'émission
ce qui ne s'est encore jamais passé
c'est à dire que jacques pierre le
réalisateur n'est pas encore dans le car
nous attendons claude françois boyer qui
a déjà une partie de l'équipe de claude
cayla à personne des charmantes
claudette claude et quelque part dans la
foule est ce que nous allons retrouver
ça je l'espère en tout cas
voyez est une émission en direct ça nous
vous le disons à peu près tous les jours
mais comme ça vous en rendez bien compte
dit don't lie claudette je vous trouve
bien habillé chaudement aujourd'hui
d'habitude au mois de novembre en corse
vous arriver comme ça avec vos petits
bas résille offert des robes des
morceaux de robes et aujourd'hui alors
encore une nouvelle tenue c'est claude
un qui décide d'écouter les gens là on à
l'école en descente c'est claude qui
choisit costume est ce qu'il vous
demande votre avis qui les destinent
d'ailleurs il vous demande pas votre
avis en général il a bon goût alors on
est obligé d'accepter george vi et puis
toujours obéissante bien sûr
dites moi vous savez tout danser mais
finalement est-ce que vous savez chanter
aussi les unes et les autres
bah oui mais scotchante de notre dernier
disque c'est quoi l'amour toujours
l'amour l'amour toujours l'amour et tout
à l'heure où aller nous interpréter
l'amour toujours l'amour d'accord oui
tiens je vais voyez je vais vraiment
faire devant vous les missions comme si
vous étiez avec nous sur le plateau
brigitte brigitte venez voir un peu tant
pis c'est votre deuxième passage ce
n'est pas une claudette brigitte et
notre assistante et croyez moi qu'elle
se donne du mal comme tous ceux qui
travaillent avec nous
brigitte est ce que j'acquière est
retourné dans le cas lors il n'est pas
encore il ne va pas tarder mais il n'y
est pas encore et encore à la recherche
de claude je dois dire qu'il ya des
milliers et des milliers de personnes ce
formidable on ne se plaint pas vous
pensez bien voyez la banque dévoile
alors si vous voulez vous allez dans le
car si nos amis ne m'entende pas pour
autant demander nous interpréter l'amour
toujours l'amour va alors passer le
temps comme ça vous êtes d'accord
alors vous y allez alors je pense que
dans quelques instants
nos amis les clodettes vont vous
interprétez l'amour toujours l'amour
voici
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
merci claude bonjourbonjour didot on est
particulièrement content de te voir
ouais ya eu des aventures je suis arrivé
en même temps que tout le monde alors ça
a été long à arriver
bien sûr enfin le principal c'est que tu
sois là je vais te dire qu'on a eu peur
la 'tanière' enlevé par la foule non
mais tu ne s'obtient pas un dans pas
deux c'est toujours agréable tu sais
qu'il y ait ces arts jeunesse pendant le
mois de juillet 80000 vacanciers alors
c'est à dire quoi
on en a une bonne partie là j'ai tout vu
sur la route en arrivant c'est une
région magnifique la connaît déjà cette
région non qui la découvrent enfin que
je découvre ça choque c'est ravissant
que c'est c'est un petit un petit
patelin perdu dans les pins qui est très
très bon reebok avionnais les montagnes
derrière qui tombent dans la mer un
petit peu comme en corse ailleurs et
c'est désagréable que nous avec l'équipe
des mets dix premières nous sommes ravis
de sillonner toute cette région du
roussillon
tu es arrivé de paris ce matin oui hier
lire soir dans l'instable mehdi dompter
en plein gala là en ce moment tu vas ou
de ton prochain gala lieu quand mon
prochain gala et ce soir à béziers aux
arènes de béziers se faire à béziers bon
ben on endort j'ai juste à côté vrai
et après où vas tu restes dans le midi
ou tueur par ailleurs angela plus riches
continuent ailleurs mais je m'en
souviens plus tu vas dans les arènes de
béziers ce soir arènes de béziers où les
quotas déjà un aperçu de la foule qui va
du chant magie
voilà cette distribution des bises et
alors maintenant bonjour toi mais tu en
as une belle casquette abondé enfants
vous avez en face à l'ennemi siro voilà
dix mois claude tu as encore deux
chansons nous interpréter je raconte un
peu l'émission depuis des records
tu sais qu émission a commencé pendant
que jacques pierre t'accueillir qu'il
était encore en bas aventure avec toi
vous y l'émission a commencé
et à l'heure ce sont les claude et qui
ont interprété la chanson dont tu as
écrit les paroles et la mort toujours
l'amour c'est une jolie chanson sa très
jolie chanson les thèmes bien toi comme
ça faire chanter un petit peu des gens
qui font avec toi
de temps en temps puis les clos depuis
longtemps galles dans cet intéressant de
les voir des butins chanson faut dire
que c'est quand même restreint pour un
départ mais c'est agréable à écouter un
puisqu'il ya c'est qu'on a vraiment
l'impression qu'elles forment une très
très bonne équipe autour de toi c'est
vrai tu les aimes bien alors j'ai dit
que bien sûr le grand thème de
l'émission aujourd'hui c'était l'amour
d'ailleurs l'amour c'est toujours dans
toutes les chansons qu'ils sont
interprétés
et puis en même temps bon nous aurons
tout à l'heure également une chanson qui
est très jolie qui te tient certainement
très à coeur et que tu vas chanter en
duo
ensuite tout expliquer maintenant je
voudrais poser une question à
jacques-pierre parce que je ne sais pas
quelle chanson il a l'intention de te
faire interpréter maintenant 6 et laisse
une chance à notre amour comme nous
sommes ici avec les clodettes et que tu
une interprète avec les clodettes ou si
c'est le duo alors j'aimerais
j'aime laisser les chances d'accord
alors pour l'instant que l'autre chante
laisse une chance à notre amour
on y va mais oui
l'enveloppé normée naba avons très bien
très bien
tu viens claude parce que à niort on y
va on nous allons essayer d'arriver
jusque là bas
nous avons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre ami clos de serre des milliers et
des milliers de mains est vraiment de
personnes de tous les âges à la fois les
enfants les grands mères les jeunes
filles enfin tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
et il est très agréable de voir la joie
qui brille dans les yeux de tous ceux
qui approchent claude également la joie
qui prient dans les yeux de claude
canton
j'espère que nous allons quand même
finir par arriver auprès de la presse sa
jolie cas pin
qui va chanter avec claude dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]
donne-lui d'ancrage au fantastique
dans la chanson pour l'instant il ya
tellement tellement de monde autour de
nous que les haut parleurs sont
décrochés on fait vraiment grande grande
panique temps va arranger tout ça mais
tu sais bien il ya tellement demande les
haut parleurs soins qui peut cacher
derrière des pieds il ya des filles qui
se tirent alors je pense que tout ça va
s'arranger très vite en attendant on
pourrait présenter cathelineau
téléspectateurs catherine
bonjour merci d'être là ça nous fait
très plaisir de vous accueillir et
d'autant plus que nous savons que claude
est très heureux ouais c'est vrai je
suis content avec elle yaël elle ne
parle pas un mot de français
elle n'est pas si on nous a dit si on
nous entend t'inquiète pas
elle ne parle pas français alors je peux
traduire si tu veux mais où il a dit
rencontrer au et les dents c'est que
j'ai une agence de mannequins il est
elle fait partie de la chance mannequin
j'ai rencontré comme ça a très bien et
américaines american you are in american
girl elle bien douées los angeles que
reviendront aux lèvres et
you leave in french
depuis combien de temps ça fait un one
year one is all à la bravo parce que de
biens non est-ce que vous avez déjà une
quête lui demandait ce qu'elle a eu déjà
l'occasion de visiter notre beau pays
devraient défendre
la première fois alors elle ne connaît
pas encore toutes les régions mais on
pour chanter avec toi donc je crois
qu'elle va connaître un tournant toutes
les régions
les marées vertes ou enfin n'est pas
toujours avec avec moi dans les galas la
juste qu'elle dise mais c'est qu'on ne
sait pas vraiment son métier à la bombe
sur le sel n'est pas la réponse mais je
sais que nous avions entendu cette
chanson nous avions vu pour la première
fois d'ailleurs sur tf1 était très jolie
regarde un peu les jolies fleurs
je crois qu'on est en train de nous
parler mais nous n'entendons rien nous
avons un ronflement sur le haut-parleur
là derrière les personnes est vraiment
pour l'instant ça il y en a plus de
renseignements on n'a plus rien du tout
alors rejette un peu fanée moeschler
on vas tu es gentil mais je la partage
avec cabine merci claude bon alors là je
me suis arrêté quelques instants j'ai
regardé derrière la caméra
parce que maurice oria l'un de nos
cadres heures vient de me transmettre ce
que j'acquière nous vous fait dire étant
donné qu ici nous avons des problèmes de
haut parleurs alors nous retournons de
nouveau voilà on se promène beaucoup
dans cette émission allez on y va on va
là-bas à voir la tension devenait
kathleen com
mai dernier on voit par là aller
mais si messieurs les gendarmes année
tout le monde vient
[Musique]
eh bien on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons une fête argelès plage ça ne fait
pas l'ombre d'un doute
vaud où tout le monde non seulement nos
amis dargelès sont très nombreux mais en
plus ils ont une forme moi je suis sûr
que ce climat du roussillon et de la
côte vermeille leur réussit
particulièrement
[Musique]
voilà que des invités dans quelques
instants